all right next up on the program jb
shrobble is here
he is the founder and ceo of redwood
materials but
you probably know him as
one of the co-founders of a little
electric car startup
from here in the silicon valley called
tesla and uh welcome to the program jb
hey great to be here thanks for having
me yeah so we've known each other
forever um i'm
50 feet away from my tesla roadster
number 16 and my signature model s0001
uh what an amazing journey you had at
tesla
tell me just if you were to recap the
experience
from roadster
model s to model three
and all the near-death experiences for
the company
uh how do you look back on that amazing
journey in your life
oh man it's uh it's like trying to recap
you know uh the encyclopedia britannica
here um it i mean it's it's such an
adventure you know i i just kind of look
back on it all um
you know mild disbelief and you know uh
you know some of the the brutal you know
near-death most difficult stuff kind of
gets you know a little bit tempered even
with just a little bit of time and um
you know i don't i just feel incredibly
proud to have like been a part of this
you know crazy revolution and been at
the right time in history when all this
was possible and we were able to do
these things
and the batteries seemed to be the key
component here there was something about
that time period when
y'all started working on tesla and
making it work
where correct me if i'm wrong
but battery technology from
uh the
smartphone revolution and the laptop you
know boom of the late 90s into the 2000s
played some sort of role in
uh setting the the groundwork for tesla
to be able to do
what you did correct
yeah it was pivotal and and i think that
that was you know if there's a luck to
it that was the lucky timing and and
some of it was intentional
but uh lithium-ion batteries you know
were commercialized in about the year
2000 for laptops and sony did that
you know it was bleeding edge you know
then and
you know three years later tesla starts
and you know or five years later uh you
know we're building them into the first
roadster next to you so you know that
that was
it was that sort of beginning of you
know the that decade that uh you know
presented that kind of opportunity and
before that you just couldn't make a
modern electric car they just they
weren't technically feasible you could
only do so much with you know nickel
metal hydride or lead acid batteries
um
i remember one stat that you know we
would constantly kind of talk about or
think about and it's that you know the
roadster
when it was fully charged the whole car
you know with a person sitting in it has
an energy density higher than a lead
acid battery
so
you know there's no physical way you
could take these this like old
technology and make it you know perform
that way so that that was what made it
possible
and the cost of the original battery
pack in that
roadster was somewhere in the 40 000
range 50 000 range if i remember
correctly
yeah it was in that ballpark it was you
know close to a thousand dollars a
kilowatt hour
wow you know so i think uh 53 and change
kilowatt hours in the first generation
roadster and uh yeah probably around 50
to 55 000 or something in there just for
the battery pack just for the battery i
replaced my roadster battery pack with
the 300 plus mile one i think for 25
dollars
uh x number of years later and now i can
go 350 miles although you probably
wouldn't want to drive for six hours in
a roadster it might be a better mission
for the y need a chiropractor after that
you you did feel
um you did feel the road in the roadster
um
but it was mind-blowing tell me what it
was like to deliver those first hundred
if you take your back yourself back to
that time period
and
people on the road in la and in the bay
area and those first hundred getting
delivered and i guess larry sergey and
yourself uh bill lee david sacks myself
there was just like a group of people
who put those
sixty 160 dollar deposits down for those
first hundred signatures
what was it like when you delivered
those first hundred signatures
i mean it was it was incredibly
rewarding and exciting you know we were
obviously pretty late
delivering them in the first place
just a little bit um and uh
you know and all these early customers
just were such a key part of the the
company and the mission back then it was
it was kind of you know this sense of
camaraderie you know making this happen
um
and yeah we were i mean we were super
proud of it you know we put our heart
and soul into that thing and and uh
you know worked on it for so many years
as a pretty small team and obviously it
was very different you know profile then
you know
much much lower profile um
but you know to see a modern electric
car out there and having customers
actually enjoying it and experiencing it
doing you know multi-hundred mile drives
it was it was pretty amazing i mean that
was revolutionary people didn't
you know most people would still think
we were lying actually about the range
you know in those days which was amazing
that is uh
such an accurate description of that
time period is the fear uncertainty and
doubt that was being
directed at you and and tesla
was insane and you know we're driving
the cars yeah
150 200 miles and telling people look
it works and they're literally saying
nobody will ever buy an electric car
because
of range anxiety and i'm like i'm
charging the thing once a week in la
you know it's my daily driver i drive
you know whatever 10 miles back and
forth to santa monica to the office and
um
i'd literally had people jump in the car
when i would be at valets and just say
please take me for a ride around the
corner please just i want to experience
the
the exhilaration even at that time
before ludicrous mode i don't know what
the 0-60 was on the roadster but it was
four seconds or 3.7 or something yeah i
think yeah just just under four for the
sport model but it
you know it was the same experience
though i mean it you know minus the
whole all the creature comforts and the
nvh and the handling and a bunch of
other things
you know a few little things um but that
that same experience of getting in there
you know feeling the torque feeling a
0-60 in under four seconds
um
it you know it i was driving the
roadster last weekend um and it's
amazing how you could like feel the dna
of what electric cars became and have
are today you know even in that that
early thing
if you don't have business insurance you
failed one of the first steps in being a
great entrepreneur startups should look
no further than in broker
e-m-d-r-o-k-e-r
and brokers technology saves you time
and money prices are up to 20 lower and
you're gonna get better coverage than
incumbents and you go from sign up to
quote and purchase in just 10 minutes
when you work within broker instead of
business insurance incumbents you're not
dealing with these large slow
corporations and the sign up takes just
days not weeks the process is completely
transparent there is no opaque pricing
and i'm going to quickly explain two
crucial types of insurance you need
cyber insurance what does it cover it
covers hacks they happen all the time
and you need to have coverage for that
plus
d and o insurance this is
for your directors
people on your board and officers the
top five or six people of the company if
somebody does something dumb and you get
sued you need to protect the directors
and officers because they're responsible
and even if you don't do something dumb
and somebody still wants to sue you
because people can sue you for any
reason they could be wrong you could be
right it doesn't matter you need to have
the insurance online so you can protect
yourself so
instantly buy custom built insurance for
startups go to
inbroker.com twist
e-m-d-r-o-k-e-r-dot-com
twist and while you're there get an
extra 10 off by using the offer code
twist okay let's get back to this
amazing program